[Music]
zenimax media has been awarded five
hundred million dollars in its lawsuit
against oculus which alleged the virtual
reality technology it owns was stolen
and used to develop the oculus rift I'm
Lucy and welcome to King's what news
updates first a parent company ZeniMax
had been seeking two billion dollars in
damages and four billion in punitive
damages from oculus following several
days of deliberations a jury today found
oculus libel of copyright and trademark
infringement as well as having breached
to ZeniMax a nondisclosure agreement it
was cleared on claims of trade secret
theft and unfair competition facebook
was found not liable while oculus is
responsible for 250 million of the half
billion owed to ZeniMax the two
companies weren't the only defendants
oculus executives were also named and
have been found liable former oculus CEO
Brendan arabi who recently stepped down
for a different role 150 million for
trademark infringement while founder
Parma lucky and CTO John Carmack each Oh
50 million notably Carmack is a former
ZeniMax employee a key issue in the case
was whether work Carmack had done at
ZeniMax and maple the creation of the
oculus rift as you'd suspect ZeniMax
believes it did and argue that code used
to power the oculus features indications
it stems from ZeniMax works according to
law 360 Carmack and others claim none of
the code he worked on at ZeniMax was
used in the version of the rift that
existed on Facebook bought oculus comic
did admit to having copy emails and
source code from his time as any mics
but claimed he wrote new code while at
oculus ZeniMax also alleged that Palmer
demoed VR games created by Carmack in
the early days of oculus existence and
that these helped make it possible for
the company to be founded
the case dates back to 2014 when ZeniMax
first filed suit last year and Carmack
and Arabi to the list of defendants with
more specific allegations oculus has
consistently stated that the case has no
merit in a statement shared with
GameSpot oculus called attention to the
areas in which it was found not liable a
spokesperson said the part of this case
was about whether oculus stole ZeniMax
is trade secrets and the jury found
decisively in our favor we're obviously
disappointed by a few other aspects of
today's verdict but we are undeterred
oculus products are built with oculus
technology our commitment to long-term
success of VR remains the same and the
entire team will continue the work
they've done since day one developing VR
technology that will transform the way
people interact and communicate we look
forward to filing our appeal and
eventually put in this litigation behind
us in its statement ZeniMax said it was
pleased with the outcome and that it can
now seek an injunction to prevent
continued use of the code it owns we
will consider what further steps we need
to take to ensure there will be no
ongoing use of our Miss appropriate
technology including by seeking an
injunction to restrain oculus and
Facebook from their ongoing use of
computer code that the jury found
infringed ZeniMax is copyrights so what
ramifications do you think the outcome
of the trial will have on oculus is
future be sure to let me know in the
comments below for more on oculus make
sure to LIKE this video and subscribe to
gamespot
[Music]